did you realize that 93 of a burger has
originated
from corn 93 of that burger has come
from corn if you're doing burgers from a
fast food restaurant of course i'm not
talking about grass-fed burgers i'm
talking about corn-fed beef
there was a interesting study which i'll
put down below that evaluated 480
fast food burger joints
in new york
and they looked at something called
carbon 13
and corn has the most of this versus
other things you would feed a cow and
they found that 93 percent of the
tissues in the hamburger was created
from corn and they also found chicken
had a similar profile if you didn't see
the movie king corn
you should check that out i'll put a
link down below
fascinating on the relationship between
corn and our own body cells they talk
about a fascinating link between
the food that we eat
and corn actually getting into our dna
as well and so the very building blocks
of animals and humans are becoming
corn based
not to mention soy based
and wheat based
the great majority of our food that we
eat comes from corn soy
and wheat
now even the so-called healthy
plant proteins that they're going to be
putting in the meat come from soy
wheat gluten
and potato starch and they're also
thinking about putting corn in there as
well it's called corn zine which is a
byproduct of ethanol and of course it's
so badly processed they make it sound so
healthy when they talk about plant
proteins
but first of all using gmo plants that
are highly processed so you get all
these residuals of
solvents and other chemicals that you
really don't need in your body i
remember in college
basically living probably for three
months
on
fast food because i was running out of
money and i would get like two burgers
for a buck
one dollar for two burgers i mean that's
an incredible
uh deal right but of course what are you
really getting i could only imagine what
those cows ate and of course back then
uh i ate the bun i everything with it
but coming to the present i consume a
lot of hamburger of course without the
bun i might use lettuce wraps i might
use cabbage wraps or just the burger
itself but it's always going to be
grass-fed so there's really nothing
wrong with the burger itself but there's
a lot wrong with what the cow is fed and
how the cow is processed or treated
while it was alive but there's some
interesting things about fast food
burgers that i want to talk about and
number one which i'm going to put the
studies down below on all these points
they found that 12
of the actual burger itself
came from muscle meat
the rest came from
sugar sorbitol
meat glue
which is a certain enzyme and hydrolyzed
corn protein here we go with the corn
again and of course with the muscle meat
there's also
tendons ligaments cartilage blood
vessels nerves and even bone which i
don't mind all that stuff but i do mine
all the other stuff they add to it now
when a cow is fed actual grains the
omega-6 versus the omega-3 ratios go way
out of balance so you're going to get a
lot of omega-6 which are highly
inflammatory now the cows that i'm
raising right now are living on grass
but in the winter we feed them some hay
which is fermented as well as something
very new that i'm experimenting on which
is sprouted barley seed in fact they go
after it like piranhas so sprouted
barley is called fodder and you can feed
that the animals and it's super healthy
and you can grow it very inexpensively
and within like seven days that would be
a substitute to feeding the cattle
grains now in a typical burger and
restaurant there's very very very high
sodium there's over a thousand
milligrams of sodium which i'm not
against sodium but i like it to be in
the form of sea salt not just sodium and
also many people are deficient in
potassium so the more sodium you have
when you don't have potassium it's
really hard on the kidneys so the more
sodium you have make sure you balance it
out with potassium but really make sure
it's in a form of sea salt and then you
have of course the other thing which is
glyphosate which is in the gmo
corn soy which feeds the animals
glyphosate is an herbicide that destroys
the soils and it can severely affect our
bodies as well it can actually sterilize
the soil now since we're on the topic of
soil i want to talk about antibiotics
over 80 percent of the antibiotics sold
are used for animals that's probably
because they're feeding grains and that
grains create a lot of problems with
their digestive system and their immune
system there was a study in 2018 which
evaluated
burger joints and they found 23 out of
25 of those
restaurants contained meat that had
traces of antibiotics now the big
problem with antibiotics for animals is
the increased antibiotic resistance so
in other words the more that you take it
the more chronically you're exposed to
it the more that animal or human becomes
resistant to that antibiotic and they no
longer work and so now we get these
breeds of superbugs that we can't kill
and there is some pretty hardcore data
which i'll put down below that shows
that the antibiotic resistance from the
animals can be transferred over to
humans they call this a non-therapeutic
antibiotic i mean when you think about
it most antibiotics come from
microbes in the soil
from either bacteria
or
fungi and so these microbes are really
really smart because they
created this antibiotic to kill
the more deadly pathogens in the soil
and so this is their way of surviving
and keeping everything in check and of
course when we come in and destroy the
soil we pretty much sterilize the
environment and we wipe out the
antibiotics and now the pathogenic
microbes and funguses can then thrive so
really the
strength of the immune system in a plant
and also our bodies is dependent on the
immune system of the soil and the
microbes that live in this environment
and so this idea of steaming the soil
they actually do that they actually can
sterilize the soil by putting this hot
water on it it kills up the microbes and
it literally takes like four years to
grow it back
those microbes are essential for
mobilizing the minerals and rocks to
make them available for the plant and so
when you try to grow food in soil that
doesn't have these microbes
you have to add fertilizers you have to
add a lot of minerals to try to make it
fertile again and of course they don't
add all 94 minerals they pretty much add
three
npk nitrogen phosphorus and potassium so
this is the food that is created in the
soils that feed the animals this is the
food that we're getting we're getting a
lot of missing things from the food
because of the soil being so infertile
now back to this burger they also put
another chemical in the burger to kill
off pathogens it's called sodium
diacetate
just as the icing on the cake and then
of course we have the condiments we have
the mayonnaise the ketchup okay filled
with soy filled with corn as in high
fructose corn syrup and then of course
those fries are deep fried in corn oil
and your soda that you have with the
burger is basically corn as in high
fructose corn syrup not to mention the
bun
being refined wheat
corn
because they use high fructose corn
syrup and that and they put some soy in
there and sugar from beet sugar which is
gmo and then sprinkle some synthetic
vitamins and then we just mix in a dough
conditioner to make it really the great
texture that we love other than that
they're totally healthy so it's a really
good idea to make your own burgers make
sure you get the grass-fed grass
finished if you're going to use a bun
make sure it's keto friendly but i
wanted to show you this next video that
i did on one of the healthiest foods
that you can eat which is a high quality
burger i put it right here check this
out
you